Barack Obama returns to slam president
Trump's coronavirus response and the
release of Michael Flynn States debate
when to reopen and the media attempt to
create American conflict over the tragic
killing of a smut our Barry I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the benton shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn calm / man well I
hope that you had just a wonderful
relaxed weekend since all of the days
have now bled from one into another I
hope you got outside I hope you got
outdoors a lot of people outdoors
yesterday at various places that that my
family was going and that's a good thing
more vitamin D is good you know socially
distance make sure that you're not
infecting the elderly don't walk into an
old-age home or anything like that
other than that get outside it is good
for you okay so let's begin with some
good news today I know I know we're not
allowed but good news good news so there
are a couple of different studies and
these are controversial that suggests
that it is possible the children are
actually not infecting their parents
there are a couple of different studies
that are along these lines in
Switzerland there was a study that
suggested the kids were not actually
infecting their parents that they were
apparently either getting a low viral
load of of Kovan 19 or if they were
infected they were not passing it along
to their parents and therefore this
really is adult-to-adult transmission
the kids are actually not infecting the
people around them which would be really
good news you basically mean that it's
time to open up the schools because the
key with opening up the schools is not
that we are afraid kids are going to
infect each other we've seen I believe
double-digit deaths in the United States
maybe in terms of the number of children
who have died total across the United
States under the age of 20 the numbers
are insanely insanely low this is just
not a dangerous disease in terms of
death for those who are under the age of
20 in fact in terms of death it's really
not even that dangerous for those under
the age of 30 so long as you don't have
a significant pre-existing condition if
those people cannot even pass along the
infection well then what you're really
talking about is it's time to get all
those kids back to school because even
if they come home having been in having
been hit with kovin 19 they're not gonna
pass it along to mom and dad there's a
study from Iceland that suggests exactly
this according to science museum group
org dot uk'
they did an interview with Roger high
fields he's the science director in in
in Iceland and they talked with Kari
Stefansson the CEO of the Icelandic
company decode genetics in Reykjavik
which is study the spread of Kovan 19 in
Iceland with Iceland's Directorate of
Health and the National University
Hospital Kari Stefansson says that
children don't seem to be passing this
along actually which obviously is really
really good news they say children under
10 are less likely to get in fact
than adults if they get infected they're
less likely to get seriously ill what is
interesting is that even if children do
get infected they are less likely to
transmit the disease to others than
adults we've not found a single instance
of a child infecting parents in Iceland
not one which is kind of shocking
because pretty much every flu bug that
I've gotten in the last three years has
been for my kids if you have kids you
know that there are little germ
factories they go to school and they
interact with all the other little germ
factories and they come home and they
spit on you and now you're sick well if
it turns out that Kovan 19 is actually
not impacting children the same way as
adults and in fact children are not
transmission vectors then that is really
really good news meanwhile other good
news the u.s. rates are continuing to
decline Scott Gottlieb former head of
the FDA actually tweeted out a chart
yesterday showing that in the last week
the united states ran an average of
270,000 tests per day with the total of
more than two million test runs the
number of tests is going steadily up and
the number of positive cases are
continuing to go down so the United
States continues to see a decline in the
in the rate of positivity now it is
possible but this is the after-effects
of likely that this is the after
effective lockdown right lockdown means
that fewer people are out there
interacting with other people and you're
not seeing a spike in the cases what it
does mean is that we are not in any
danger right now of overwhelming the
health care system like at all we are
that is not a danger now if there's a
massive spike could we be on the verge
of overwhelming the health care system
again sure theoretically although the
fact is that the biggest population
center in the United States New York was
already really really hard hit and even
in New York and in places like New
Jersey the the main disease vectors
happened at old-age homes so what that
means is that if you're if you can
protect very specific spaces as we're
going to talk about then you have a
better shot of tranching populations
which is something I've been talking
about since the very beginning another
piece of good news Scott Gottlieb
tweeted out an important finding that
was put out by a by a group in I believe
this is Great Britain and the finding
was that it was put out by a series of a
series of professors immigrant Gabriella
Gomez Ricardo aguas Rodrigo kurta what
they found is that it is possible that
herd immunity to kovat 19 does not
require 60 to 70 percent of the
population be immune they say that
because there's variation in
susceptibility meaning that kids do not
pass this thing along and there's a lot
of people who obviously are not
supremely vulnerable
19 if you want to hit herd immunity you
may not actually have to hit 60 to 70
percent of the population you may only
need to hit 40 percent of the population
which would mean that the policy of
attempting to stop the spread completely
is actually wrongheaded Scott Gottlieb
points out that this would radically
changed the math he says let's take New
York zero prevalence studies done early
or show up to 20 percent were exposed to
kovat it's higher now as the epidemic
groups of 30% of the New York City
population
Cyrille convert the city could be closer
to hurt immunity than the 60% presumes
needed which would be a huge story right
that would be a really really good piece
of news we'd probably see that first in
Sweden right because Sweden a heavy
percentage of their population already
has had kovat 19 the antibody test in
Sweden are showing well over 30% a place
like Stockholm already have had Kovan 19
already have antibodies for Cova 19 and
apparently they're starting to see a
collapse in their death rates those are
the early reports is finally they're
starting to see that long way to
collapse in their death rates I'll give
you a little more good news in just one
second because there are there's a major
race for a vaccine going on right now
we'll talk about that momentarily first
let's talk about the fact that you are
online a lot right now and you know
who's really online a lot people who
would love to implant malware on your
computer people who would love to steal
all your data people who'd love to screw
up your computer or hold it hostage this
is why you need PC Matic PC Matic is a
whitelist next-generation antivirus
program designs to stop modern threats
like ransomware this is when somebody
puts a bug on your computer and then
basically locks all your files unless
you pay them independent testing from
av-test just named PC Matic as the top
performer in a cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019 only PC Matic has American research
development and support PC maddox
competition is very often made in
foreign countries many where the virus
has originated so it is possible that
they're particularly vulnerable to new
viruses not PC Matic PC Matic will block
annoying and malicious ads for
hassle-free web browsing makes your
computer faster and more reliable even
after years of use n it works with
virtually all of your systems XP Vista
Windows 7 8 and 10 windows servers Macs
MacBooks Android phones and tablets you
should be protecting yourself against
malware and ransomware there's nothing
more annoying than your computer getting
hit with it and maybe nothing more as
expensive PC medical just fifty bucks
for five devices for one year which is a
great way great cheap way of protecting
all of your intellectual property with a
full 30 day money back guarantee if you
act now PC Matic is offered Milas and
there's a free month
security protection with the purchase of
an annual license to access the offer
but a PC Medicom /ban again get
world-class security that keeps your
computer running fantastically well go
to WWE seem adhikam /ban that is pc
manic calm / man protect your computer
now again 50 bucks for five devices for
one year with a 30-day money-back
guarantee it's not gonna get much better
than that go check them out right now PC
Medicom slash bet okay other pieces of
good news so they're a bunch of
competing vaccines that are now on the
table according to wired.com it's been
four months since researchers in China
sequence the novel coronavirus known as
covin 19 at least 3.8 million people
around the world have been diagnosed
with kovat 19 as a Friday morning more
than two hundred sixty-seven thousand
people have died a vaccine could stop
the virus before an infection can take
hold and we are seeing a bunch of
different options that are popping up
clinical testing generally has three
stages as wired phase one involves a few
dozen healthy volunteers phase 2 expands
to several hundred and outbreak area and
phase three repeats the experiment with
several thousand then FDA officials have
to review the data and decide if the
shot is safe and effective enough to
approve all of these these vaccines are
basically being accelerated there are a
bunch of different vaccines that are on
the table there is one from a company
called moderna there is one from the
Oxford group there's one from can see no
biologics so it is possible that we are
moving toward a vaccine as well so that
is a fair bit of good news the johnson &
johnson chief science officer actually
came out yesterday and he said listen a
vaccine is probably gonna be available
this year which would certainly be good
news as well is there any possibility
that the hope that the President had
calls for earlier in the week that there
could actually be some kind of an
effective vaccine in 2020 is that
realistic at all well clinical trials
will need to be done to show that is
effective and that will take some time
we will have some vaccine available this
year but it will depends on it will
depend on the authorities the FDA and
others to decide whether it can be used
earlier before the clear efficacy data
are available okay so hopefully we are
looking at the possibility of vaccine
sometime later this year okay all of
these pieces of good news suggest that
the lockdown policies that we are
pursuing right now are not exactly the
smartest move the
they're not the smartest move is because
one of the things that is obvious that
lockdown has prevented the spread which
I assume is good news but in when I say
I think it's good news it's good news in
the sense that if you're hoping that
something is magically going to change
then you've bought yourself some time
but the strategies that are now being
pursued are simply not being accurately
portrayed by the media so we are seeing
experts who are saying things like we
need tens of thousands of contact
tracers before we can reopen well just a
question what is contract tracing
designed to do in the United States it
is designed to prevent viral outbreaks
by real massive outbreaks but we are
going to know that because of the the
fact that so much of this is transmitted
a symptomatically we're first going to
know about the outbreak not by people
contact tracing individual cases per se
because gonna be very difficult to
contact rice for people who are
asymptomatic you're mostly going to know
that when people start showing up at
hospitals on mass right so this works
when you have a zero baseline in terms
of cases a contact tracing works in
South Korea but it only works in South
Korea so long as people are locked down
for a significant period of time as soon
as the lockdown sent by the way South
Korea is seeing a spike again now Scott
Gottlieb is pushing fast-acting testing
he says that maybe if we can get really
fast acting testing that that might be a
game-changer one of the problems with
the fast-acting test is they are 85%
effective 85% ain't 100 in fact it ain't
even close to 100 85 percent means that
you could go in and there's a 15 and 100
chance that you still have the thing in
your testing negative for it so that is
not exactly comforting when you're
talking about the massive kind of
numbers the United States has in terms
of human beings who could be moving this
virus along here with Scott Gottlieb
yesterday on CBS News and by the way
when I say that the purpose of testing
is to prevent the spikes that overwhelm
the healthcare system you know who told
me that Scott Gottlieb on one of our
Sunday specials so this is not coming
from nowhere I asked him specifically
what's the purpose of testing he said
the purpose of testing is not to wipe
out the virus it's to prevent the spikes
okay so as long as you are preventing
the spikes then presumably you've got
enough testing you've got enough contact
tracers the idea that we're gonna
contract trace this thing into oblivion
is just not reality
not in a country of 330 million people
with 1.3 million diagnosed cases here's
Scott Gottlieb kind of technology is a
real game-changer in this test was
authorized by the FDA under the
leadership of Jeff Jarrett who runs that
device center in 24 hours from
keeping the application what it is it's
a very rapid test that can be used in a
doctor's office doctors now have about
40,000 of these Sofia machines already
installed in their offices and you do a
simple nasal swab and the test itself
scans for the antigens that the virus
produces the test is about 85% sensitive
so let's say a hundred people come into
a doctor's office who have covered
nineteen eighty five of them are going
to be able to be tested positive with
this test very quickly okay but the
problem is what about the other 15 who
then go out and they spread it I mean
the fact is that in 85% effective test
is better than a 0% effective test but
even in 85% of effective tests what that
is going to do is it's going to prevent
the the overwhelming of the healthcare
system which was the point of the
lockdown so I understand we've now
shifted our talk about what the lock
downs were designed to do they were not
designed to slow the spread indefinitely
but they were designed to do is prevent
the spread from overwhelming the
healthcare system I cannot emphasize
this enough the narrative has change and
the reason the narrative has changed
because we have now shifted from a world
where there was an actual time line to a
world where there is no time line the
world of slow the spreads we don't
overwhelm the healthcare system assumes
then when we don't overwhelm the
healthcare system and we get low enough
below that medical resources line then
people are going to have to start moving
back into work because otherwise the
economy is completely stopped and also
because eventually there is gonna need
to be some form of herd immunity whether
it comes through vaccine or whether it
comes naturally and then the question is
all the risks and the rewards of the
various policies but what you've seen in
sort of the public terminology about all
this stuff is that lockdown policies are
now being justified for their own sake
meaning the proof of the lockdown is
working is that the spread is slow but
we already knew that that's what lock
downs were designed to do the question
is what the endpoint of that is if you
shift it into we're supposed to lock
down and definitely to slow the spread
the indefinitely means that there is no
endpoint it means there is no time line
and people are simply not going to abide
by that especially when it is perfectly
obvious at the moment we leave our homes
I'm constantly astonished by the media
treating it in shocked fashion when
there are increases in diagnosed cases
after lock downs in what's you think was
the purpose of the lockdown you idiots
of course if the lock downs were good
for anything it was to prevent people
from infecting each other but the
purpose of the lockdown was not just to
prevent people from infecting each other
it was to prevent people from infecting
each other to the level where the health
care system could not cope with
everybody the media is that the media's
cover
the stuff is just garbage really is
terrible I mean it's really really bad
media coverage I mean the fact is that
when we look at Asia for example the
lockdowns have been ending and you know
what's happening there cases are spiking
there too so we get blamed here in the
United States oh well you know you end
lockdown in Georgia you're gonna get a
spike in cases South Korea is seeing a
spike in cases according to The Wall
Street Journal more than 50 cases have
been linked to a 29 year old man who in
a single night last week visited five
clubs and bars in a popular Seoul
neighborhood health officials said he
tested positive on Wednesday the same
day that South Korean government rolled
out relaxed social distancing measures
the country of roughly 51 million people
hasn't resorted to a lockdown like the
US and Europe instead South Korea relied
on aggressive testing tech heavy contact
tracing and a willingness by many to
stay indoors yes but that's because they
were diagnosed with like 10,000 cases
total they never had the giant
widespread cases and again I have a
question if the South Korean government
was rolling out relaxed social
distancing measures than they were in
fact in part lockdown right relaxed
social distancing measures implies that
there were pretty harsh social district
social distancing measures meanwhile
meanwhile we are seeing an uptick in
other areas of the world as well South
Korean president moon jae-in spoke
Sunday after a new cluster of
coronavirus cases emerged in Seoul he
said it's not over until it's over South
Korea was among the first places to deal
with the coronavirus epidemic and seem
to be on track to loosen restrictions
after weeks of social distancing
measures and careful surveillance but
now they're going to re-up the
restrictions again meanwhile I think
that it's important to know when people
look at some of the models and not South
Korea but even South Korea actually if
you look at the models in Asia one of
the things they've been doing is stuff
that we just would not tolerate in the
United States I'll explain it in just
one second like they're actually doing
things we will not tolerate in the
United States in a free country
I'll explain first let's talk about the
fact that you are at home right now but
you got a problem with your car can you
really afford right now to go to an auto
parts store not just because you're
gonna be standing in line but also
because that store is probably gonna
overcharge you instead you should be
using the power of the interwebs
rockauto.com
it's much easier than walking into a
store and demanding quick answers to
things like is your Odyssey and LX or
Annie X and then they have to order the
part online anyway because it's very
rare they have it in stock and then they
overcharge you if you're a professional
or if you're a do-it-yourselfer
rockauto.com is a family business they
serve auto parts customers online
they've been doing it for 20 years go to
Rock Auto comm shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of
best of all prices at Wroclaw TOCOM are
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
part the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com it just
does not make sense to spend more money
and go out to places where you don't
need to be when you can do all this
online and save money while doing it go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro and then how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you ok so as i say it is important to
recognize that while we people in the
united states in the media particularly
look at south korea the car what if we
just didn't like south korea like satin
like contact tracing you know you no one
know what's the thing that the South
Korea has been doing if you test
positive for Cova 19 they literally
remove you from your home and they put
you in a dorm there's a thing that you
think that Americans are gonna tolerate
this according to The Wall Street
Journal across swaths of Asia from
China's coronavirus epicenter of Wuhan
to Singapore in South Korea the
well-known strategies of tracing and
testing have worked in tandem with a
third big logistical task and this is
the part nobody's been talking about
because they think that Americans will
just ignore this isolating mild cases
outside their homes a sprawling
Singapore exhibition center known for
hosting an aerospace show now has
thousands of beds for patients with mild
or no symptoms see test positive for a
coma 19 and you feel fine and they're
good they will say to you you're gonna
infect people in your house you now need
you we will force you to stay in this
jail cell along with a thousand other
people effectively South Korea used
dormitories including those belonging to
Samsung life insurance and LG Display
company for the same purpose people who
test positive can either declined to be
isolated in these facilities nor remain
at home so Chris Cuomo would have
immediately been carted off to some
facility to stay with a thousand other
dudes in you know in a mass facility in
Vietnam in Hong Kong
what relatively contains outbreaks have
made it possible for hospitals to take
in both mild and severe cases
authorities have gone a step further
they separate not just confirmed cases
but also close contacts of the sick and
facilities so you're not even infected
and they will take you and they will
throw you into some sort of confinement
this approach is the Wall Street Journal
points out is vastly different from much
of the west where those that need
medical care are admitted to hospitals
while mild cases are largely asked to
self isolate many
like health experts in Europe and the
USA it's time to change that others
argue it goes too far by constraining
civil liberties and separating people
from their loved ones well yeah I don't
think the American people are up for
that you think that if my wife were to
get kovat 19 I would be like okay honey
I'm sorry we're gonna have to ship you
off to a facility for two weeks run by
the government like my parents like what
are you talking about what do you tell a
because we don't even know how this
disease works I mean what if my parents
are asymptomatic because they have a low
viral load and then they go somewhere
they get a heavier viral load like we
don't know anything about how this
disease works yet and this is pretty
incredible stuff but nobody has reported
on this in South Korea many mild cases
were isolated at home but authorities
converted corporate dormitories equipped
with little more than beds Wi-Fi and the
occasional television for those who
weren't in critical or serious condition
they actually amended their infectious
disease law allowing it to take action
against those who refused to follow
orders
individuals could not contest the
decision so how exactly do you think
that that's gonna work in the United
States that sound like a good plan for
you in the United States yeah I didn't
think so
it meanwhile the media continued to push
these lockdowns is the only possible
solution even though again they are not
a solution they are not a solution and
there's a piece and and they're
particularly not a solution when you
talk about the countervailing problems
here including the complete collapse of
the world economy there's a study that
came out last week suggesting there
could be 75,000 deaths of despair from
suicide drug and alcohol abuse that
seems like a low-end estimate to me it
seems to me likes to me a lot more than
that if you're talking about 20 percent
unemployment which is what we are
talking about at this point but again
the language around the lockdowns has
changed it went from don't swamp the
system to what if we just kept this
thing tamp down indefinitely this is why
you see people like there's University
of Washington professor on TV yesterday
talking about we're gonna see an
increase in cases yet we know that
that's not the question the question
isn't whether we see an increase in
cases the question is whether we have
the medical capacity to deal with the
cases that come in and by the way the
truth is that when it comes to medical
capacity and people being swamped most
of the people who ended up on
ventilators died rather the 90% people
who ended up on ventilators died so all
of the talk about ventilators and the
Trump administration's shortcoming with
regard to ventilator
talk about the media completely blowing
it the media we're focused on
ventilators day in and day out
ventilators ventilators ventilators now
turns out we're gonna have way too many
ventilators there's a piece according to
these so according to the Associated
Press the they literally titled piece
becoming king of ventilators may result
in unexpected blood so the media for
four months pounded trump on you're not
handing out the ventilators quantal we
don't have enough n Slater's we need
ventilators so Trump was like okay we'll
ramp up the ventilators even invoke the
defense production act for the
production of insulators now we're gonna
have like a hundred thousand ventilators
and it turns out doctors aren't even
using ventilators because in ventilators
may in fact be exacerbating the problem
especially for people who are coming in
and they can breathe okay but their
oxygen saturation isn't very good so it
but apparently Trump is to blame when we
have too many ventilators and also when
we have too few ventilators I say here's
this University of Washington professor
noting oh yeah by the way um there might
be additional cases as we open up yeah
we know we know the question is what is
the purpose of keeping us locked down
and there may be a purpose may be the
purpose is we think that we're not gonna
be able to stop the infection hitting
vulnerable people
that's a purpose so then tailor your
strategy so we can protect the
vulnerable like for example at the
old-age homes here's this University of
Washington professor what's driving the
change is simply put the the rise in
mobility and that's the key driver we're
seeing in some states you know a twenty
percentage point increase in just ten
days
in mobility and that will translate into
more human contact more transmission our
suspicion is that there will be about
ten days from now in these places that
have had these big increases in mobility
we are expecting to see a jump in cases
of course we're expecting to see
drumming cases the question is what is
the purpose of preventing the jump in
cases and don't tell me you're
preventing deaths when you literally
don't have a strategy for preventing
death for people who are infected and
you also understand that right now
people are gonna get infected that the
minute you let people out a lot down
there will be additional infections and
we cannot stay lockdown forever because
it turns out 66% of new infections in
New York or based on people who are
members of the family staying in the
same houses with other people I'm gonna
give you some of the dishonest arguments
that are being made by so-called health
experts and again there are a lot of
health experts who are on the other side
a lockdown argument like a lot of them
have talked to many of them the question
right now is not the science everybody
kind of agrees on the science there will
be more infections there will be more
deaths we don't necessarily know what
exactly the infection case fatality rate
the infection fatality rate is it could
be anywhere from point 2 to point 6 in
all likelihood but we do know that more
people out there will be mean more
infections that's not the question the
question is what is the strategy and the
dishonesty when it comes to approaching
the strategy is quite incredible get to
that in just a moment first let's talk
about the second amendment so if you're
a believer in the Second Amendment
you really should have a gun that works
before you and let me tell you the
Second Amendment has never been more
important I mean we're watching
seriously as local law enforcement is
basically being informed by the
politicos that they should not actually
enforce the law I have a friend down the
block the other day who literally I'll
get to this later in the program I
really have a friend who was robbed
within two days and like two days ago
somebody tried to rob their house and
the only reason these people ran is
because the guy had a gun and then the
police came and said we can't do
anything about it cuz we have zero bail
here in Los Angeles so all that will
happen is that we'll arrest them and
then we'll have to let them out of jail
the same day so what's the purpose of
even arresting them I mean this is
insanity having a gun in order to defend
yourself and your property and your
family makes a hell of a lot of sense in
order protects against the destruction
of American rights you know breeze with
me Bravo Company manufacturing BCM
builds a professional-grade product a
built to combat standards this is
because BCM believe the same level of
protection should be provided to every
American regardless if they're a private
citizen or a professional the people of
BCM assume that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or
soldier overseas with that in mind every
components of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans the
people of BCM feel it is their moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that are not gonna fail the user
when it's not just a paper target but
somebody coming to do them harm okay
owning a firearm is not about just going
target shooting or going hunting it is
about protecting yourself protecting
your rights to learn more about Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm you can discover
more about their products special offers
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm if you need more convincing find
out even more about BCM and the awesome
people who make their products at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA that
is Bravo Company MFG comm let them know
we say they're great great people okay
so let's talk for a second
without the case in favor of lock
there's a piece by Liana when emergency
physician and visiting professor at the
George Washington University Milken
Institute of Public Health she served as
Baltimore's health commissioner okay so
she she talked about six arguments that
are made in favor of ending lockdown
so here the here the arguments that she
says are bad instead of preventing cope
in nineteen we should let people infect
each other to achieve herd immunity
she says herd immunity occurs when
enough people in a community generally
sixty to eighty percent
develop antibodies to an illness either
through vaccination or recovering
banking on herd immunity without a
vaccine is a dangerous proposition it's
unclear whether people acquire immunity
after contracting Kove in nineteen if
those who recover become immune an
infection rate of 60 percent could mean
nearly 200 million infected Americans
millions could die okay so question what
there's no vaccine
there's no therapeutic do you have an
alternative like seriously what is your
alternative whenever people say we can't
allow her to mmunity to take place
vaccines create herd immunity that is
the purpose of X of vexy and by the way
we do not have good information that
there have been reinfection x' we've had
false positives on tests there's not
been good information that people are
reinfected after they develop antibodies
for kovin 19 so I keep wondering people
say herd immunity is very bad we can't
allow her to immunity it's super
dangerous do you have an alternative
again protect the most vulnerable point
of developing herd immunity is let's say
that you need sixty percent of people to
get Kovan 19 in order to develop herd
immunity right because then there's just
not enough people the replication red
drops below one because they're not
enough people who can pass this on what
if we could theoretically ensure that
the people most likely to get kovin 19
before herd immunity is reached are the
least vulnerable so for example let's
say 60% let's say let's say 70% your
population is young and healthy right
people under the age of 40 children
people who don't have significant
pre-existing conditions not people in
old age homes in other words let's say
you can protect the people who are most
vulnerable and ensure that the people
who are most likely to get kovat 19 are
people who are younger and people who
are healthier well that would probably
be the safest way to do this right I
mean that is the controlled Avalanche
strategy because not everybody is
equally likely to die of coma 19 even if
everybody is equally susceptible to
getting Kovan 19 may argument number two
most cases of Kovan 19 are mild we can
keep older people home and allow young
healthy people to go back to school and
work first she says this is wrong from
multiple reasons and she's gonna have to
explain that literally every policymaker
in Europe in the United States because
that is the plan guys that is the plan
that is the plan in Israel it is the
plan in Sweden it is the plan in Italy
it is the plan in Germany that is the
plan everywhere she says older people
aren't the only ones contracting covin
nineteen one in five patients requiring
hospitalization in the United States are
aged twenty to forty four okay first of
all that suggests that four and five are
over the age of fifty basically infected
people in their 30s and 40s are dying of
strokes this is one of my my I am so
irritated by the lack of statistical
exactitude in pieces like this when she
says infected people in their 30s or 40s
are dying of strokes that's true are
they doing so in mass numbers are we
seeing thousands and thousands of cases
of people in their 30s and 40s dying of
strokes the answer is no we are not
right so when you equate the chief
method of death for Cove in nineteen
which effectively is you die of
pneumonia after you get Kovac 19 because
your lungs stop functioning properly you
actually drown it's really it's really
horrifying then we need--we conflate the
rate of that in older people versus
infected people in their 30s and 40s are
dying of strokes that is not an
intelligent response you need to give an
actual statistical breakdown shows even
if young people are not as likely as
older individuals to become severely ill
that can be asymptomatic carriers who
spread the virus okay but the entire
presupposition of your argument here is
that we were going to protect the older
and vulnerable so even if they're
carriers and they carry it to people who
are less vulnerable that's not that big
a deal and then she says okay people are
getting sick and dying from other
illnesses and greater numbers than Cove
in nineteen she says this is a bad
argument for lock-in she says it's true
that emergency department visits for
other illnesses are decreasing
inpatients are issuing medical treatment
because they fear risking infection
allowing the corona virus to spread
without restrictions would lead to a
hospital overcrowding further inhibiting
patients from obtaining necessary care
controlling the pandemic would create
confidence and increase people's
willingness to seek care for other
conditions okay well again I agree but
that goes back to the overwhelming the
health care system right you do want to
make sure that as we release here we
release the healthiest population so you
don't overwhelm the healthcare system
the question is not what percent of
population and what percent of
hospitalizations are young the question
is what percentage of young people are
being hospitalized those are two
separate questions
and then she says it's worth the
sacrifice if some people dies in this
country as a functioning economy she
says this is a false choice I agree it's
a false choice I agree to false choice
nobody is
saying that it is worth the sacrifice if
some people dies to the country as a
functioning economy what we are talking
about is the inevitability of infection
and how do we get past this the fastest
so that we reduce the amount of death
and reduce the amount of human suffering
so what does she do to respond to that
argument instead she suggests that if
you're in favor of ending lockdowns
tapering off lock downs it's because you
don't care about people of color that's
that's his literary lecture sections
minorities and working-class Americans
of all ethnicities unable to shelter at
home will continue to bear the brunt of
infections illness and death individual
liberty cannot take precedence over the
health and well-being of less privileged
ok nobody is suggesting that we want to
send people who are vulnerable back to
work if you are if you are a black
person who is vulnerable you should not
go back to work under these conditions
if you're an elderly hispanic person you
should not go back to work under these
conditions
nobody is urging that to happen we
should make provision for you but if you
are a young healthy 25 year old hispanic
man you should probably be think about
going back to work especially if you're
not living with somebody who is 60 or
over and then she says we've been in
lockdown for more than a month and cases
aren't declining social distancing
doesn't work no we know that social
distancing doesn't work nobody's making
that argument and finally she says it's
a bad argument to end lockdown because
we can't keep the country in lockdown
until the vaccine is developed which
could take years she says no one is
arguing to extend stay at home orders
for years but reopening criteria is set
by the White House's own coronavirus
task force have not been met removing
restrictions too soon would have
predictably grim at results okay but you
have not offered an alternative again
there are no alternatives offered it's
amazing how many people just say
lockdown when there are no alternatives
offered and as you'll see this
translates over into public policy so
for example JB Pritzker who is the
governor of Illinois he said yesterday
that we will continue this until we are
it will continue the lock downs
indefinitely literally indefinitely
we'll do it pretty much forever
until there is some way to eradicate it
before we would have a vaccine assuming
maybe we never get a vaccine we're gonna
have to deal with you know hopefully a
treatment that will come along that will
be very effective but even without that
everyone's gonna have to wear a mask
we're still gonna have to socially
distance the truth is that coronavirus
is still out there it hasn't gone
anywhere and so we all are going to have
to change the way we do things until
we're able to it
dedicated that that is we're not gonna
be able to change anything until we're
able to eradicate it so we're walking
down so we can eradicate this good luck
with that then you have Andrew Cuomo
suggesting maybe physical schooling is
actually over maybe we'll stop
physically schooling children and then
you're gonna make a case the kids have
to go to public school as opposed to
homeschooling explain Andrew Cuomo you
know the old model of everybody goes and
sits in a classroom and the teachers in
front of that classroom and teaches that
class and you do that all across the
city all across the state all these
buildings all these physical classrooms
why with all the technology you have
it's not about just reopening schools
when we are reopening schools let's open
a better school and let's open a smarter
education system he said maybe remote
learning could be the wave of the future
so we're just gonna end schools now how
does any of this productive policy it's
quite possible by the way even according
to a lot of experts that closing the
schools was a mistake in the first place
because it actually put kids at home
with mom and dad and grandpa and grandma
speaking of blown public policy this is
the same Andrew Cuomo who says oh yeah
yeah by the way reversing our nursing
home policy it was his garbage nursing
home policy that forced nursing homes to
take back in people with Kovan 19 that
probably led to a vast spate of deaths
in New York hospitals going forward
cannot discharge a patient to a nursing
home unless the patient tests negative
for covered 19 so we're just not going
to send a person who is positive to a
nursing home after a hospital visit he's
a hero because he wants lock down this
dolt didn't put these policies into
place until May until the middle of May
so from the beginning of March to May
the policy in New York State was if an
80 year old goes into the hospital it
tests positive for kovat 19 send them
back to the nursing home that was the
policy in New York here over the
Republic Andrew Cuomo and I'm supposed
to listen to him about how lockdown
policy is supposed to work I'm not gonna
trust leaders like Andrew Cuomo are you
or JB Pritzker like to these people
sound like they have any sort of
calibrated approach to this issue I'll
tell you who does sound like they have a
more calibrated approaches
Mike DeWine in Ohio right Mike DeWine
has been very Pro locked down throughout
this process he's opening this thing up
and he was asked okay well you haven't
exactly hit the white houses you haven't
exactly hit the white house's marks as
far as the sustained level of decline in
cases why are you doing that he says
because the purpose of the lockdown was
to prevent people from overwhelming the
healthcare system and we have measures
to prevent that from overwhelming the
health care system this is a person who
actually understands what lock downs
were designed to do as opposed to
everybody else who keeps dragging on
these lock downs because they have no
idea what they were designed to do
apparently what we do now have chris is
is great capacity in regard to testing
we did not have that two weeks ago we
are standing up a big force of people to
do to go talk to people to run that
virus down isolate people so those are
two things we did not have before that
it's a work in progress we're getting
that by the way worth noting Brian Kemp
the governor of Georgia who's been
ripped up and down for reopening he
actually put out a tweet yesterday
saying guess what guys actually we are
seeing some fairly low hospitalizations
every time there's a bit a bad day in
Florida it turns into you reopen and now
people are dying but they never report
when there's a good day in places like
Georgia Brian Kemp said today marks the
lowest number of Kovan 19 positive
patients currently hospitalized
statewide since hospitals began
reporting the state of April eighth
today also marks the lowest number of
ventilators and use 897 with another
2,000 available we will win this fight
together also worth noting and talk
about projections in California cases
and deaths rising more than expected
we'll get to that in just one second
because it is worth looking at the over
at the at the overall numbers in terms
of you know excess deaths meaning how
many deaths over normal is Kobe 19
providing in states like California
we'll get to that in a second plus we're
gonna get to Barack Obama who's
reinserting himself into the political
debate I'm sure that Donald Trump is
most excited about all that he loves
that's me we'll get to that in just one
second first I want to take a moment to
tell you about Daily wires newest
exclusive membership tear the all-access
Insider tear the all-access insider
memberships here is our premier is our
premier level of membership all access
members get the benefits of our other
membership tiers including an ad-free
website experienced access to all of our
live broadcast and show library access
to the shows mail bags and the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
along with dedicated editorial
from yours truly all exits members also
get other amazing benefits including of
course the singular irreplaceable
leftist years tumblr they also get to
join live exclusive online queue nays
daily wires new discussion feature
available on both the website and the
daily wire app they also get to
participate in all access live our
brand-new interactive programming
feature joint featuring one of us daily
wire host as we hang out with you each
night tonight tis I so you can watch me
do bizarre things like whistling over at
daily wire comm if that is something
that excites you greatly head on over to
daily wire.com slash subscribe to join
daily where's all-access club with a new
membership or an upgrade get 10% off
with coupon code Shapiro that is daily
we're calm at Slash's subscribe we'll
see you there you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as I say there's a new study out
today suggesting that California is
gonna see a major spike in cases the
Christopher Murray who is the director
of the University of Washington's
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation that is the IHM II study that
is constantly being used that model he
says some states where cases and deaths
are gonna go up more than we expected
Illinois then Arizona Florida California
researchers are predicting California
could see more than 6,000 Cova 19 deaths
by the end of August up from 1420 from
projections released on Monday the
upward revisions are a result of the
combination of updated daily death and
case data recent actions these
previously implemented social distancing
measures and steadily rising levels of
mobility in many places California added
about 2,200 coronavirus cases in 64
related deaths on Saturday 40% of the
new cases were reported by LA County
which makes sense to population center
as were 45 of the new deaths they are
now up to the state is now up to about
2,700 deaths statewide okay now here's
the question the question is how many
deaths is this overall in in California
because California is a state of forty
million people so 40 million people
let's hit there 6,000 deaths by the end
of August for 40 million people hey on a
weekly basis on a weekly basis in the
state of California 1200 people die of
heart disease 1,100 people die of cancer
on a weekly basis we're talking up at
the end of August right now it is May so
if you're talking about 6000 people who
die of this by by August and then let's
say you fast forward that let's say you
double it for the year so you end up by
12,000 by the end of the year which
would be a high number right it's a big
number 12 that every life lost
horrifying and tragic you're still
talking about something that charts at
like number number 5 perhaps number 4
number 5 in terms of death causes in the
state of California in the state of
California you see something like 207
and 240,000 people die every year in
California so it is an increase it is a
significant increase but it is not a
doubling of the state rate of death in
the state of California when you talk
about covered 19 right it's really again
it's really bad
but it is important to put that in
perspective if you are talking about the
total number of deaths that are going to
be attributable to kovat 19 over the
entire country over the course of the
next year
probably talking about increasing the
deaths in the United States by somewhere
between four and five percent total it's
not a fifty percent increase is not a
ten percent increase to five percent
increase horrible terrible no good we
should do whatever we can to prevent
that but the question is how do we
prevent that how do we stop that the
fastest and locking things down all
that's gonna cause honestly here's
what's gonna happen
States the lock down are going to see
people leave so any one must basically
said this yesterday said listen I'm just
gonna move Tesla out of California right
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna stick around
here
he said Tesla is filing a lawsuit
against Alameda County immediately the
unelected and ignorant interim health
officer of Alameda is acting contrary to
the governor and the president our
constitutional freedoms and just plain
common sense because they continue to
keep the factories shut meanwhile
speaking of lack of common sense over in
Washington State and a bunch of
different a bunch of different states
actually they've been lowering the
ability of police to actually prosecute
criminals in the middle of all of this
as my friend Jason Rance writes over at
Katie th days after governor jay Inslee
coronavirus prisoner release plan three
inmates fresh out of jail are accused of
reoffending which of course is not a
shock and as I mentioned a little bit
earlier yesterday LA now has rules
there's no bail to be had right that you
go in you're immediately released no
bail to be paid because we want people
out of jails cuz people aren't affecting
each other in the jails so yesterday my
friend his brother lives next door to
him his brother was robbed by three guys
he just walked right into his house and
he was at home at the time he's the only
one at home at the time and he shouted
my friend his brother immediately
grabbed his gun because he lives next
door and racked the shotgun these guys
took off down the street they called the
police the police said they literally
had these guys on tape they had them on
tape because they have security cameras
the police like two tires nothing we can
do about it because if we arrest them
they're just gonna be out within five
minutes so we now have our police who
are unable to do anything you think
people are gonna want to live in states
like California where you can't go to
work where even with social distancing
you are still having pressure put on you
not to open your business where if you
are a landlord right if you're somebody
who actually leases properties to others
you've been told that you cannot receive
rent for a year not kidding for a year
because for six months
there's coronavirus relief meaning you
don't have to pay your rent and then for
another six months takes another six
months just to adjudicate whether you
can be evicted in places like California
you think any anybody who has the means
is gonna stay in California there's me a
mad rush to get out of California if
this kind of policy continues especially
if the policy does not seem to be
calibrated to actually ending this thing
ASAP and when I say this thing I mean
both Copa 19 and the lockdowns okay
meanwhile yeah President Obama is
sounding off on this so it's very easy
to be Barack Obama because you are never
blamed for any of your own mistakes it's
pretty incredible in Barack Obama's
administration was chock-full of
corruption from Eric Holder and Loretta
Lynch Kathleen Sebelius's at HHS the IRS
they're a bunch of scandals during the
Obama administration who's treated with
kid gloves the entire time because as
America's first african-american
president and as a historic president
President Obama was just treated with
absolute lavish love by the media at all
times
well this means that his perception of
his own presidency is wildly skewed he
suggests that the response by the
federal administration here has been an
absolute chaotic disaster as though he
would have handled it any better again
I've yet to hear the Democratic policies
recommended in February that would have
done anything to stem what has happened
here Barack Obama might have a harsher
view of states that are reopening but
there's no evidence to suggest that that
is a better view than the states that
are actually doing the reopening Barack
Obama did a conference call with his
Obama supporters in advance of 2020
here's what he had to say it has been an
absolute chaotic disaster when that
mindset what's in it for me and to heck
with everybody else when that mindset is
operationalized in our government yeah
what what attack with everybody else who
is what is he talking about
who has that mindset that straw Manning
of people who just disagree with his
policy predilections the straw Manning
of well you don't care about other
people obviously right all you do is you
your is it's just every man for himself
dog eat up nobody's talking about that
what the hell are you saying
what are you saying again it's amazing
to me Jared Paulson Colorado's pursuing
the same policies as Brian Kemp in
Georgia and nobody talks about Jared
palace or Tim Walz in Minnesota or the
governor of Maine or the gunner in
Montana Steve Bullock who never shut
down in the first place but according to
Barack Obama this is complete
about the chaotic disaster in the
dog-eat-dog mentality that sort of
high-handed garbage coming from Obama is
nothing new it by the way he didn't stop
his criticism there he also suggested
and this was even more ridiculous he
suggested that the release of Michael
Flynn the refusal to prosecute Michael
Flynn is is all about politics inside
the administration as opposed to you
know when Eric Holder was calling
himself Barack Obama's wingman and
Loretta Lynch was meeting on the tarmac
with Bill Clinton while Hillary was
under investigation now that wasn't
political at all no power no
politicization from the Barack Obama DOJ
as Barack Obama knew personally about
the Michael Flynn phone calls and was
directly asking people in the chain of
command below him who should have known
like Sally Yates about Michael Flynn in
White House Oval Office meetings no
corruption at all no corruption at all
when the Barack Obama FBI and Barack
Obama DOJ were working together with the
tacit assumption that the Trump that the
Trump campaign was colluding with Russia
and then they're willing to bend
virtually every rule in order to pursue
that line of attack here was Barack
Obama attacking the Trump administration
for supposed corruption or Michael Flynn
for someone who's been with perjury just
get off scot-free
that's the kind of stuff where you you
begin to get worried that pacing not
just institutional but our basic
understanding of law is is it risk
okay he's I'm sorry he was a joke when
he was president he was constantly in
high-handed language doing exactly the
same sort of tribal izing activity with
regard to American politics he accuses
other others of by the way there is
actually very good precedent for
prosecutions being dropped against
people because of corruption inside the
prosecution and at the high levels of
politics you know what there's no
precedent for trying to prosecute a
national security adviser on the basis
that he had a conversation with the
Ambassador from Russia that is not
threatening that person with the Logan
Act that is insane it's insane okay and
then not turning over exculpatory
evidence there's good evidence by the
way of charges being dropped for lack of
the prosecution doing what it was
supposed to do perfect example same
judge in this case in the Flynn case
judge Sullivan of the US District Court
for the District of Columbia back in
2009 he killed the prosecution of
Senator Ted Stevens of Alaska who was
convicted of violating federal ethics
laws it turns out it turns out a team of
prosecutors from the DOJ did not hand
over key exculpatory evidence and
knowingly presented false evidence to
the jury they killed the prosecution of
Ted Stevens as well so actually there is
a fairly solid precedent for this The
Wall Street Journal points out even
discounting Obama's partisan audience
this gets the case willfully wrong Flynn
was never charged with perjury lying
under oath in a legal proceeding Flynn
pled guilty to a single count of lying
to the FBI in a meeting at the White
House and he was led to believe was a
friendly chat among colleagues as for
scot-free that better applies to former
President Bill Clinton who lied under
oath in a civil case and was impeached
for perjury but then was acquitted by
the Senate we understand why Obama
wouldn't bring that up also the fact is
that Obama was in the loop on this stuff
I mean from what we understand Barack
Obama was in the loop on what his team
was doing and then he is talking about
corruption inside the Trump DOJ for
killing a prosecution that was obviously
malicious in intent
pretty pretty wild stuff from Barack
Obama but
it's got to be easy when you've spent
your entire when you've spent your
entire political career being immune to
slings and arrows it's pretty easy to
throw stones is it not already and let's
get to some things that I hate so as I
mentioned the media coverage throughout
the pandemic has been abysmal the media
coverage over the Flynn stuff is abysmal
the media have utterly be clowned
themselves throughout a time when you
actually need trust an institution so
our political leaders don't appear to
have a clue as to what they are doing
Andrew Cuomo in New York is saying
things like only now am I going to start
you know washing the subways and making
sure that the elderly are protected but
my policies on lockdown are the best in
the media are cheering him along my
favorite is Chuck Todd so Chuck Todd had
himself a weekend man so Chuck Todd he
started off by suggesting there's no
plan for what comes next from the
administration because every time the
administration presents a plan you just
suggested is not a plan it seems like
the only plan the Chuck Todd and company
want is the plan where everybody shuts
down or they just shout tests and trace
on all the time when testin Trace is not
actually a realistic strategy for a
country of 330 million people with free
movement and 80% asymptomatic
transmission here's Chuck Todd to say
the administration's response to this
coronavirus pandemic has been both
confused and confusing and it raises
troubling questions what's the plan for
testing and contact tracing or does the
federal government think that's just too
hard to do without a breakthrough what's
the plan for maintaining social
distancing as states reopen what's the
plan for making people feel tough and
about returning to work when even the
White House can't keep the virus out and
what's the plan for treating this
pandemic is our greatest national crisis
since the Second World War in other
words what's the plan okay but you have
not actually expressed what you think
the plan is and then you you blame Trump
when he allows other states to involve
their own plans so which is it you want
him to take national control or would
you like andrew cuomo and gavin newsom
to lead the way are you angry that we
are too loose are you angry that we are
too strict what exactly are you talking
about and again by the way the media
have been abysmal throughout this the
media every day we're going to the White
House and asking about ventilators
because Andrew Cuomo was talking about
ventilators it turns out that there was
a 90 percent death rate on ventilators
they may have actually been
counterproductive in many cases and by
the way we're not gonna need to close to
100,000 ventilators these
the press as I mentioned earlier is now
reporting that we didn't need all these
ventilators we're gonna have a surplus
in ninety thousand ventilators guys but
you were saying that Donald Trump was
evil for suggesting that New York would
not need 40,000 ventilators which by the
way New York did not need hey then that
wasn't even the worst moment of the of
the weekend for Chuck Todd Chuck Todd
his show on NBC deceptively edited bill
Barr so bill Barr the Attorney General
and he's the one who decided they're
gonna drop charges against Michael Flynn
on the basis that basically the
prosecution had not turned over X not
turned over evidence showing that they
were attempting to manipulate Flynn that
they had no basis for the prosecution of
Flynn in the first place essentially
that they tried to drop the
investigation against Flynn at the
beginning of January and then it was
revivified just in time to try and
pressure him to turn on other members of
the Trump administration or at least to
go after him so that he would be outside
the chain of command so bill Barr made a
statement the statement the bill Barr
made was that history will judge whether
this was the right decision even though
history sometimes written by the winners
and so we may end up on the losing side
of that the reality is the reality
NBC deliberately miscut the clip of bill
Barr to make it look as though he is
going to rewrite history in line with
his own desires it's just I mean I'm
sorry this is just media corruption I
want you to listen to this bill Barr
answer to a question about what will
history say about this where do you hear
this answer take a listen when history
looks back on this decision how do you
think it will be written well history is
written by the winners most largely
depends on who's writing the history
okay he cuts it off right there which
sounds like Oh what are the winners so
we're gonna rewrite the history that's
not what he said that's not what he said
here is the rest of that goods we have
the rest of the clip
okay here's what he here's what he
actually said he said history is written
by the winners so it largely depends on
who's writing the history but I think a
fair history would say it was a good
decision because it upheld the rule of
law it helped I and it upheld the
standards with the Department of Justice
and it undid what wasn't in justice so
he wasn't saying that we're rewriting
history because we have the power to do
it they literally cut the first two
lines and then forgot the rest here's
the rest of what Bill Barr had to say
history looks back
on this decision how do you think it
will be written well history is written
by the winners so it's largely depends
on who's writing the history but I think
a fair history would say it was it was a
good decision because it it upheld the
rule of law it helped it it upheld the
standards of the Department of Justice
and it undid what wasn't an injustice
okay so the media portrayed this as
though it was bar basically triumphal II
stomping on the rule of law that is not
what he is doing there just be clowning
themselves in dramatic fashion my way
Meet the Press later without a little
sweet apologize oh yeah yeah sorry we
miss a DES did that really I mean that's
amazing by the way that led Chuck Todd
to say what bar doesn't even bother to
make the case he's upholding the rule of
law literally in the next sentence he
makes that case in the very next
sentence so Chuck Todd should either
fire one of his producers or Chuck Todd
you take two hit for this one cuz it
really has been I was struck Peggy by
the cynicism of the answer it's a
correct answer but he's the Attorney
General he didn't make the case that he
was upholding the rule of law he was
almost admitting that yeah this is a
this is a political job no he wasn't he
literally said it in the next sentence
well done our trusted mainstream media
by the way speaking of our trusted
mainstream media media watchdog brian
Stelter so brian Stelter yesterday who's
very very upset that people recovering
flynn in the right-wing media that we on
the conservative side we're covering
Michael Flint now let's be real about
this there are people you know I my
friends and Bungie knows been covering
this Flint stuff in depth for a very
long time right in making that case with
alacrity I gotta be honest with you I
wasn't super interested in the Flint
stuff until all the facts started to
come out at the very end here and when
bill bars DOJ really exposed to the
public light the entire set of facts and
circumstances surrounding Michael Flynn
okay there were people in the right-wing
meet Mark Levin was covering this thing
at length in ways that I was not that's
true okay but that's newsworthy I
covered it like a lot last week because
it is extraordinarily newsworthy when it
turns out that the Obama administration
at the very top levels of the
administration knew that its own that
its own FBI was basically skirting the
rule of law in order to go after Michael
Flynn threatened him with a Logan Act
violation a law that has not been
prosecuted successfully no
fifty years and then attempting to spin
dross into gold simply because everybody
inside the chain of administration was
convinced that the only reason Trump
could have one is because of Russian
interference and collusion so brian
Stelter got mad about this and brian
stars like why are they even covering
this but why don't they cover kovat why
weren't they covering kovin they only
want to talk about flynn you guys talk
about russia non-stop for two and a half
years non-stop and then you talk about
ukraine for another half of a year are
we allowed to talk about the fact that
like the Obama administration basically
because they were so convinced that
Trump was evil and a Russian Lackey
decided to violate the rule of law to go
after people who actually had not
committed crimes and keep investigations
into them open that they decided to
wiretap members of the of the Trump
foreign policy team people like our page
they decided to do all this on the
flimsiest of pretext because they were
convinced in their confirmation bias way
that their political opponents were the
bad guys
are we allowed to talk about that like
five minutes we just take for that okay
because I took like one episode but
here's brian Stelter saying we can't
talk about any of this I mean coab it's
happening man it's so disappointing to
look at what we're seeing from
right-wing media these days where
there's such an obsession with the deep
state and these revelations about the
russia probe and the decision about
michael Flynn they're treating the
Michael Flint story like it's a bigger
deal than the deaths of 2000 Americans a
day when the president called in to Fox
& Friends the other morning Friday
morning right before the unemployment
rate numbers came out he talked about
the Flint case for 20 minutes before he
was asked about the pandemic in what
right mind is any scandal any political
scandal any Department of Justice story
more important to ask the president
about then the pandemic that's raging I
mean is and what what I mean it's kind
of important when you're former national
security adviser is effectively accused
of treason and colluding with the
Russians then lying to other people
about it so you can flip him against
other members of the administration then
it turns out the whole thing is bullcrap
that's kind of a big deal and when Obama
knew about the calls all the way through
it turns out that Obama was aware of the
Flint phone call and was using that as a
pretext to ask members of his own DOJ
what exactly was going on with the Flint
now that's kind of a big deal I'm amazed
at Bryant Bryant him what a media
watchdog what an objective media
watchdog how dare people talk about
Michael Flynn when it's the biggest
story in the country for at least one
day amazing amazing stuff ok time for
one more thing that I hate and it's a
bit of it's a bit of a biggie so in this
case of a moto Barry R Barry right we
talked about this at length last week
right this is the case of the 25 year
old black jogger in Georgia who was
apparently spotted inside a construction
site right he was looking around at a
house that was under construction and
then somebody called the police on him
and also apparently called their friends
and this led a father and son to grab
the guns and go out and catch this guy
and so they the road blocked him
somebody else was coming up from behind
with video camera and you can see them
blocking the road this this appears to
have been by witness testimony the
second time they confronted him that's
what it kind of sounds like to me it
sounds like they've confronted him and
told him to stop and then he ran and
then they like took the car around
stopped him on the road and one of them
had a shotgun one of them in a handgun
he tried to charge around somebody
confronted him with a gun and thinking
hey why are these guys presumably
thinking this is kind of dangerous when
these guys are trying to stop me with a
gun he then went after the guy with the
gun and and was shot in the process and
now these guys are being charged with
murder right they should certainly be
charged for the least manslaughter
because the fact is that you don't go
vigilante style trying to capture people
when there is no evidence that a crime
was committed in the first place it is
not a crime to walk around an open
construction site that is not a crime
this isn't a guy charging out of a crime
scene covered in blood and then you grab
because that wouldn't be a controversy
right it's a controversy when somebody
gets called the cops on because they
were walking around an open construction
site and then the guy's basically shot
for his trouble for going around an open
construction site so there are some
people who are very upset and that folks
like me were critical of the of the
shooting of our Barry which I frankly
don't see how you can be not critical of
the shooting of our Barry given the tape
and given the circumstances so there was
a tape of our Barry inside this inside
the the construction site that was
released over the weekend and it
basically shows our Barry walking around
again
in an open construction site that's
pretty much all it shows you know there
there he is he's walking and you can see
him kind of jogging into this open
construction site because there's a
commode out front and then he leaves and
there is tape from inside the house as
well right you can see somebody spotting
him and calling the police I think is
what we were seeing on this tape if we
are contemporaneously describing so he
comes on out and and then he is going to
jog away now it is not a crime to be in
an open construction site and in fact
the homeowner who is linked to this case
and there's a picture of our berry
inside the construction site a homeowner
said his residence was never burglarized
he said I've never had a police reporter
end of it or anything stolen from my
property or any kind of robbery he was
having the waterfront home built in
Brunswick this homeowner the 911 audio
from before the shooting shows a caller
reporting a black man in a white t-shirt
at a house under construction the
operator asked if the subject was
breaking into it and the guy said no
it's all open it's under construction
he's running right now there he goes
right now and it's and the the operator
asked what the man in the white t-shirt
was doing the caller said the person was
running down the street the operator
asked again saying she needed to know if
the man in white was doing anything
wrong
the audio was somewhat garbled but the
caller said the man had been recorded on
camera before as an ongoing thing he
also mentioned man building the house
was probably not going to finish it
because of heart problems
so again no crime was actually being
committed in this particular case so
everybody was basically on board with
this investigation it turns out that
probably what happened here is that the
person the the elderly man the older man
who's been in 65 who was the father in
this particular case was very tight with
the with the DA's and one specific
prosecutor decide to kill the charges so
as an insider issue I was an insider
corruption issue is what it appears to
be now the Georgia State government is
asking the DOJ to investigate the
handling of the armory killing not just
the killing the handling of the killing
the the Georgia State governor has
displayed this has denounced the slaying
is horrific President Trump called the
shooting heartbreaking and very
disturbing Attorney General Chris Carr
said in a statement we are committed to
a complete transparent review of how the
our bury case was handled from the
outset the family the community the
state of Georgia deserve answers
we'll work with
in law enforcement at the state and
federal level to find those answers
Esley merit the lawyer representing our
Barry's parents applauded the moves
further examine what he called the
potential cover-up of a murder he said
we've requested the involvement of the
DOJ since we first took this case
they're far too many questions about how
this case was handled and why it took 74
days for two of the killers to be
arrested and charged in our Berry's
death hey that that is all this is a
good thing hey this is why it's good
that the video came out because the
right thing is happening right now we
are going to have a full investigation
of how this happened now
my theory here is that this has less to
do with racism than it has to do with
vigilantism and then it has to do with
the and then it has to do with
corruption inside a system in which X
cops get special treatment from
prosecutors and by the way it's it's
true that in certain cases cops get
special treatments from prosecutors as
well which is not a good thing right you
don't want that okay so it seems to me
that if if racism does play a role in
this it is a more subtle role than the
account that's being put forward by some
which is that these guys just decided to
hunt down a black guy that day which is
not what the tape actually shows what it
shows them trying to stop what they for
whatever reason believe is a criminal
that does not mean that it's not
manslaughter you don't get to say you
don't get to basically see a guy running
on the street or going into an open
construction say oh he's probably a
criminal I'm gonna go grab my gun and
stop him that's not a thing that you get
to do okay but this has not stopped the
media from trying to polarize this by
pretending that people are on different
sides now I don't think people aren't
different sides of this I decided you
Brian Kemp I decided you Donald Trump
now I'm a conservative virtually every
other mainstream conservative that I
know is appalled by the footage and
believes this purple should the very
least be brought before a grand jury and
should be prosecuted everybody from the
folks at National Review to the folks at
Reason magazine to the folks over at the
Federalist like everybody is on the same
page here daily why we're all on the
same page essentially which is that this
is vigilantism and vigilantism has to be
prosecuted the only controversy is
whether we know that these guys were
doing this because they were racist or
whether they were doing this because
they had or because they were they were
idiot vigilantes who decided they were
gonna go out and stop a crime that was
not being committed or that there was no
evidence of being committed this does
not stop people from trying to trying to
polarize and this is where the media
really get
this is ugly stuff so here's Don Lemon
suggesting that there's apathy about the
shooting is there apathy
I missed the apathy because I talked
about this for happened at half an
episode last week nearly a full episode
last week everybody else I know has
talked about this there been a variety
of articles written about this and some
interesting thing pieces like there's no
apathy I don't know what Don Lemon is
talking about here we are tired of
jumping on everyone else's bandwagon to
help everybody else to help women who
are fighting discrimination in the
workplace to help the me2 movement to
help everybody else LGBTQ communities
when are people gonna care us to us to
when are people gonna catch tagged us to
what are people gonna care about our
issues why should a Fresquez care about
opening up this country and rebuilding
the economy if you're gonna rebuild the
economy on our backs when we are the
people who are dying what the what what
why should it why should black people
care about reopening economy cuz they're
part of the economy
well who is who's saying that they want
black people to die look this is just
sheer malicious bullcrap from a down
lemon who doesn't care about black
people who who's saying that it's like
really what it what is he talking about
it's a deliberate attempt to polarize in
a time when again they're not very many
Americans who are saying this should go
uninvestigated and unindicted but this
sort of nonsense continues the Atlanta
mayor tried to blame Trump try to
suggest that these guys were given
permission by Trump to go black people
hunting in the middle of Georgia
it's insane I'm sorry as mayor Keisha
lands bottoms in Atlanta with the
rhetoric that we hear coming out of the
white house in so many ways I think that
many who are prone to being racist are
given permission to do it in an overt
way that we otherwise would not see in
2020 because you have to remember Jake
you know in cities across this country
even if local leadership fails there was
always the backstop of our Justice
Department to step in and make sure that
people are appropriately prosecuted but
we don't have that leadership at the top
now the DOJ is doing an active
investigation right now right now and
then there's a Vanderbilt professor who
tried to connect to our Barry shooting
with the anti lockdown protests
suggesting that somehow it's the set you
know we're a country that allows anti
lockdown people to go to the Capitol
with guns and they don't get shot but if
you're a black man running on the street
then you will get shot okay well the
people who did the shooting in Georgia
are the ones who are getting prosecuted
they are white what are you talking
about if you commit a crime you should
be prosecuted in the United States
obviously and everyone who doesn't agree
with this is an idiot there's this
Vanderbilt professor trying to you know
talk about how America is deeply racist
when we're all on the same side I've
said for a thousand times we're all on
the same side of the sort of stuff when
a bad racist things happen we're on the
same side here he is I would say that
the bigger context here about the ways
in which guns have been constructed as
symbols of white kind of white privilege
in a way the ways in which guns
particularly carrying guns in public
like this has been constructed as a way
of kind of showing a particular form of
white authority I think provides a lot
of the context for a lot of these
shootings that were that we're seeing
and particularly on the are pre shooting
okay what why does that provide context
what context by the way when I speak of
cases that are not getting national
attention here's another one
okay so here's one it's not getting
national attention why because the right
thing happened when the right thing
happens it doesn't get national
attention when the wrong thing happens
right in this case what appears to be an
insider job then it gets national
attention so here is an example so there
is a case this is from New Hanover
County in I believe North Carolina in
which an all-white mob led by an
off-duty New Hanover County sheriff's
deputy terrorized a teenager and his
family over a case of mistaken identity
and a letter addressed to New Hanover
and Pender County district attorney Ben
David James Lee claims the armed group
of armed group of people all white
knocked on the door of the home of
Monica Shepard late Sunday night Shepard
was asleep but her son Damien a high
school senior was awakened playing video
games in front of the home located in
the Avondale community in Pender County
the Shepards are black when Damien
answered the door Leia said the group
demanded to know information about a
young missing girl the group was
apparently looking for an individual
named Josiah who lived next door but
left the neighborhood a month earlier
Leigh says Damien Damien identified
himself by name several times the group
continued to
for information he didn't have there was
a person carrying an assault weapon
another with a shotgun according to the
letter also part of the group was an
off-duty member of the New Hanover
County Sheriff's Office when Damien
attempted to shut the door after telling
the group who he was the New Hanover
County deputy stuck his foot in the door
and demanded to come inside okay this is
scary stuff obviously the deputy blocked
her from closing the door as the group
demanded to come inside the attorney
said penser County deputies made no
attempt to detain or identify members of
the mob but on Friday District Attorney
Ben David and Pender County Sheriff Alan
Cutler how the press conference to
announce criminal charges in the
incident
David announced the deputy kita became
former deputy kita they fired him he's
being charged with forcible trespass
Breaking and Entering willful failure
failure to discharge duties another man
is being charged with going armed to the
terror of the community okay so why
isn't that national controversy because
the prosecutors did what they were
supposed to do so in other words what
members of the media like is when
somebody does something corrupt and bad
so they can try to imputed action to the
entire country as opposed to when the
prosecutors do the right thing like in
the case of Walter Scott in South
Carolina the black man who is shot in
the back by a police officer and then
the police officers tried to fabricate
evidence and that guy went to jail for
death for murder that's not a national
controversy because we're all on the
same side right because the people did
the right thing alrighty well we have
gone way past our allotted time but we
will see here a little bit later today
for two additional hours of content
you're listening to the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]